[Musique]
pierre après pierre théophile montrent
les tours d'entrée du château fil à
plomb en main le maçon s'assure de la
bonne réalisation de son ouvrage
ici avec notre notre combat qui ont su
bien le le rayon lattois 12 14 une
pierre de 14 15 ans minimum on a la
chance d'avoir un seigneur de guédelon
impôts ce qui fait deux centimètres et
demi exactement
c'est quand même bien de pouvoir
découvrir et garder ses anciens authier
ces outils qu'on traverse et des
milliers d'années il faut les faut les
garder il faut comprendre comment on les
utilise pour une saison ce compagnon du
devoir fait ici une étape de ce tour de
france amoureux des savoir-faire anciens
théophile a tout naturellement trouvé sa
place à guédelon
et au même temps deux mois
trois mois et on est soudés comme les
pierres
c'est quand même un petit honneur de
pouvoir prendre la relève et de se dire
qu'il ya des gens qui sont là depuis 20
ans 24 ans pour certains et par la suite
nous on peut aussi poser notre pierre à
l'édifice et et apporter un peu notre
notre grain sur sur le seul chantier
médiéval
[Musique]
cause des charpentiers lui est à
domicile
20 ans bientôt que nicolas travaille à
guédelon
c'est le fait de travailler à la main
sans machine
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait depuis
depuis plus de 2000 ans ba aujourd'hui
on est aux deux étonné qu'on puisse
encore le faire mais c'est tout à fait
normal et naturel je trouve
que je fasse un point en milliards
programme du jour équarrir une pièce de
chaîne il faut suivre la courbure
naturelle de l'arbre et surtout
préserver le coeur sa partie la plus
l'image trace le créa
quand je construis quand je fais quelque
chose je le fais du repas faut arrêter
un peu de courir après l'argent de
courir après le temps toute façon
on gagnera pas
[Musique]
à quelques mètres claire peaufine la
peinture d'une toile de lin qui servira
de fenêtres à la chapelle
il faut être quand même très concentré
c'est presque méditatif c'est fascinant
de se dire que ces gestes là en fait ce
sont les mêmes qu'il ya des siècles
et du coup yang on sent une continuité
en fait entre des générations de
peintres en fait
deux ans que cet ancien décoratrice de
l'opéra de lyon a été adopté par
guédelon ici l3 art et histoire
il ya aussi les changes avec les
visiteurs aussi qu'il y aura une partie
très importante de leur travail on est
autant artisans qu'animateur donc ça
c'est ce qui fait que les journées ne se
ressemblent jamais
au château les visiteurs se rassemblent
justement la nouvelle cage à écureuil
attire les regards et c'est avec
théophile sous l'oeil vigilant des
charpentier concepteur
attente les freins soit ami tu monte
dedans
marche plutôt sur le devant on enlève le
frein
et on est parti
quand même physique de marché donne en
fait parce que moi on marche pas à playa
du est un peu il ya une certaine pente
mais bon comme ça au moins maintenant
d'aller à la salle des sports
c'est bon c'est sûr que ça va moins vite
que les débats jusqu'au pic de xxième
siècle mais bon ça marche très bien
[Musique]
c'est à la cire d'abeille que claire
protège sa toile c'est bien c'est fini
c'est prêt la chapelle peut arborer ses
nouvelles couleurs
côté charpente l'équarrissage de la
pièce touche à sa fin
demain nous verrons comment est conçu
mulassier meding et de l'eau